justin how did your screenwriting big
break happen
that's actually a difficult question um
because i don't know if it was
one specific moment i don't know that a
big break
necessarily exists i think it's kind of
like the cliche about the actor that's
been working for 20 years and he worked
20 years to become an overnight star
you know i think it's it's more of a
series and progression of small breaks
that get you to the place where you need
to be to to get a film made or to get a
script sold
so you know i think
the the first small break in the process
was probably just
giving the script to my girlfriend at
the time who's now my wife and
having her read it and really like it
and enjoy the story
and you know be supportive and tell me
that this is
a career that i could pursue and
potentially be
you know good at uh and you know she's
still someone that i go back to all the
time to
to read first drafts of anything that
i've written she's usually the first to
read
it so i think you know that helped me
helped encourage me to
to move forward in the career that i was
doing
um in writing and i think you know
after that probably another small break
was
having approached joel david moore at
innovative artists and and
getting the script to him and having him
read it and say that
you know he really liked it and wanted
to
direct it and and star in it and produce
it and all that
um but i think you know a lot a series
of things had to happen from that point
on
we um you know having icm come on board
and be interested in it
getting barbara fiorentino our casting
director to
you know work on it and be excited about
it and bring it out to
um actors and actresses and getting them
attached that was great you know we
when we took it to icm we got danny
glover you know and that was a
small break for us and then with uh
with barbara we got you know dreyfus
to attach himself and masterson and
heater so i think
all of those accumulated is what kind of
got this particular film off the ground
now that being said
uh you know there are so many challenges
along the way
as i mentioned we had you know i
optioned the script three times the
financing fell through
on three different occasions and it
wasn't until
we brought in a production company that
financed it that we were able to move
forward
so i think being in post-production i've
seen this particular film
we've had test audiences people are
laughing and crying and really enjoying
it so i i
am very optimistic about what we can
hopefully accomplish and when we're
released you know
hopefully have um you know
a good international national release
but those are things that are going to
have to come together too
you know we we have to hopefully do well
at film festivals so that's the next
step
if we do well at film festivals and
hopefully we you know get some
recognition or
best case scenario we get some awards
that's another you know
small step and a small success and
if that all comes together getting it
into theaters and you know
moving away from a limited release and
getting a big release getting a big
distribution company to come along
you know having a lot of marketing
involved so that we can get it out to as
many people and have them
you know share in this story that we've
created so i think
i don't know that i've experienced that
one moment where i think to myself
that is a big break and that's when it
happened
i think if i ever experience that it'll
probably be the day
that i have producers and studios and
and actors approaching me and and
begging to you know
uh work on something that i've written
or or you know asking to work on
something or coming to me
uh and and wanting me to to do their
next project you know i think that's
probably where i'll feel like i've
accomplished things and i've reached a
point where
i've had a big break moment but i think
it's
as it is a business it's just very
difficult along the way and you have
small little things that help you get to
the ultimate goal which is telling your
story
and and hopefully getting a film in
theaters or if it's tv getting your show
on tv
or if it's a play you know performing it
on stage
you